multiple Krise verkrieg von Pandemie und
tiktok Esper rieselt sich so ein
humorisch noch am anderen das freie
sinnlose Spiel also eigentlich zieht die
die Suche nach Gemeinschaft dass ich
finde es schon recht offensichtlich
Autonomie und sich so sehr wichtig ist
zumindest und denn so ein bisschen
gesehen
einfach die ganze schön
[Musik]
wenn er auf tiktok oder auf Instagram
unterwegs sind kein die Challenges und
dir Tanz mit einem früheren nur dann
Macarena tanzt warum ist das so warum
suchen die Trends und was seid das
übrigens über das reden hört barbara ist
ein Video viral gegangen und zwar
[Musik]
vorbei
millionenfach oder real,-
das wird uns da sonst andere gemacht aus
dem Stück aber wenn genau
das ist ein mega
rhythmische Energie also wirklich einen
ohrwurmherzige Geburt es ist witzig
Motiv wie sich auch nicht anders wenn es
Kind wo unglaublich begeistert verzählt
wie toll es ist ein Maiskolben vor allem
mit Butter
bis ganz neu ist also wahrscheinlich
noch nie ein soundkauf Viral gegangen
ist über den Maiskolben und gleichzeitig
wirklich einfach sehr gut arrangiert das
muss man schon sagen ich finde es ist so
eine große Sehnsucht dahinter Teil sie
von einer großen großen Masse und ein
bisschen teilen und ein bisschen aktiv
machen auch körperlicht der Tanz zum
Beispiel der jerusalema
wunderschönes Lied
[Musik]
natürlich ein super Song oder wahnsinnig
und du hast immer der Bruch du kennst
hier schon du kennst ganz Schritt schon
aber es sieht nicht ganz anders
ich finde schon wahnsinnig witzig
funktioniert nur wenn es original kennst
und immer wieder der Bruchrechnen
ich glaube was Original ist ziemlich
scheißegal und Tickets die schöne
philosophische Therapie von dem
französischen Philosophie Tempo der
Simulation red also dass mir innere
waldlappen wo es Bild mir ist vor ein
bisschen realen sondern selber noch was
anderes Bild verwiesst und so weiter
also Kopie von der Kopie von der Kopie
von der kopiert und was Ursprung sie ist
eigentlich egal und das ist da so einen
Hyperrealität nennt und ich glaube als
soziale Medien in erleben genau
atomisierte Gesellschaft
und denn so ein bisschen gesehen
einfach die ganze Verhältnis
unglaublich schön also ich glaube ich
vor dass mir Philosophie irgendwelche
Zeit Phänomen diskutieren
vernünfteln da irgendwelche Argumenten
Sachen aber im Grundsatz stimmt
natürlich schon dass man wahrscheinlich
könnte sagen
noch viel schwieriger Knie und trotzdem
hat die Phänomen so nicht gehen warum
nicht Wilmes Medium nicht also die
gleiche medialen Öffentlichkeit jetzt
Tag global alle haben Youtube alle Hand
tiktok oder einfach es geht auf der
ganzen Welt das macht natürlich möglich
dass man die globale Trends hat das ist
irgendwie Form von Verbindungen
dass sie zwar wirtschaftlich sehr
globalisiert ist aber sozial gesehen nur
wenig globalisiert sind und das ist
irgendwie so ein Danke
Investoren
denken
französische
religionskultur Philosophie und der ganz
viel sein aber ein aspektor jetzt für
die Sache relevantter ist glaube ich ist
das mimetische Begehren das ist schon
Ausdruck das heißt eigentlich kopierte
Begehrens noch immer machen das ist ein
bisschen Fundament
bis einfach nur aufgrund von Tatsache
anders
kennt das
spielt sich wo die anderen Mitspieler
sind
okay
nur dort sagt das andere
besondere Challenge das weiß ich gar
nicht wie ist die andere machen wird zu
meiner Spiel und sich einfach lustig
mitspielen wenn du die einzige bist du
das machst ist bereits verflogen
Challenge für dich selber
aber das äh das Teil sie und das
partizipieren und so das ist glaube
schon Punkt
[Musik]
schreckliche Ideologie
rhythmischer tiktok glüht Mitnahme
viel besser merken das heißt Geschichte
besser erzähle sie sind anstecken das
versteht alles wunderbar und das hat die
Song so stark es steckt oh du wächst das
auch hören du machst und du irgendwo
machen das finde ich schon faszinieren
also die kulturellen
zur gemeinsame
bausteinreiche
in der Schweiz
Situation völlig losgelöst was ich
interessant finde ich schon relativ alt
also zum Teil sind auch aus alten Film
kommt
relativ alt und es geht jetzt zum
Beispiel Reportage darüber wo junge Teen
ist was mich auch irgendwie beruhigt
danke
rassistisch motiviert das weiß ich immer
oder in einer alten
aggressive Potenzial vom Humor das ist
eigentlich die schattenfreut und das
wirkt das dass das Fremdscham das
ist eigentlich
ganz ganz
oft das soziale Medien funktioniert
damit Tumor und und
lustig und das ist natürlich
super influencerinnen macht einfach ganz
schlecht
die ganze popkulturelle Trends mehr
immer zwei Arm gesehen
im im Sinn von der Kritische Theorie
dass man seit
Massenkultur Ideologie die ganze
popkulturelle Trends sind eigentlich
Ideologie das ist quasi ist perfekte
Video also das Model wo am Strand den
Bikini in Son Angst mit dem
Sonnenuntergang alles perfekt und denk
uns sehr lässt Barber wo eigentlich mehr
Theorie denn verkörpert von der culture
studies
wo ist eine Ideologie was geht unter
laufen okay
und das finde ich es geht immer aktiv
zweideutige durcharbeiten
Kritik innerhalb vom System auf der
gleichen Plattform und das finde ich es
perfide oder letztlich darum Geld machen
oder dass man mit mit Popsongs zum
Beispiel mit Rock Songs auch immer
Systeme können kritisieren ihre Art und
Weise
trennt nicht hatten können sie stehen
damit zuversichtlich versuchen zu
versunken
und das das schafft eine Popkultur das
wird irgendwie
politische Druck für mich
wichtig finden ist viel so Plattform von
der Authentizität also achthalte
irgendwie gefragt dass uns geht
natürlich
so aber es geht auch dir dass man
authentisch sie als selber sie Blabla
und da gibt's ein Plattform
2020 geht sehr schnell gewachsen wo
viele Jugendliche
ab wo eigentlich gar kein Programm heute
werden Instagram und zwar die Idee ist
wenn du da bist von der Plattform
bekommst du eine pro Tag zu irgendeinen
Zeitpunkt du warst nicht zu wählen in
aufrufen time to be real also zieht zum
8C
gleichzeitiges Wetter wie vor vorne und
vom Hintergrund und denn tut das direkt
auf das heißt du
Möglichkeiten irgendwie mit einem Filter
zu Überlagerungen
genau
aber eigentlich ist
Moment Teile mit deine Freunde hast den
ersten Linie zeigen wer du bist wie du
bist was du gerade machst gerade immer
und das ich
einfach nur so
anfangen
erzähle Interessen
vom nabelfernsehen das ist quasi Social
Media schnabelfernsehen
[Musik]
kannst
du nur um dich ja die soziale Medien und
wir stellen
regelmäßigen viral geschrieben sie ist
doch Kommentar und dann erzeugt
Sprachreisen vom Silicon Valley und da
ist über das Phänomen Influenza und wenn
verpassen abonniert doch der Kanal